first career major league start big
challenge for justin will be just to
control the nerves colton wong will lead
off
the 2-2
on the ground and alcantara gobbles it
up flips over to first
and that's the first out of the game for
justin steele two down in the batter
escovar
on the ground first ball swinging
alcantara backhands it not in time
escobar hustling down the line with an
infield hit
well positioning there i mean that's
deep under the grass one thing about
alcantara
doesn't have a whole lot of range but
he's got an incredible arm and you can
see it right there he made up a little
ground something that looked like it was
automatic base hit and escobar had to
turn on the jets keep this ending alive
it's a little dribbler third base side
steal gloves
and throws him out big guy runs well
steel able to get him
three outs on the ground
raphael ortega will lead off the bottom
of the first
here comes the payoff pitch to ortega
line drive base hit right center field
over to pick it up as garcia lead-off
single rafael ortega
ortega in his last 22 games hitting
right at the 400 clip
and with each base hit that he gets ron
he is building a stronger case for him
to be in that starting lineup on opening
day next season scoreless game first
inning in the batter now is ian half 2-2
pitch
a swing and a miss peralta with a
strikeout
his first of the game second out of the
first inning
now wisdom will take inside a check
swing the ball gets away from the
catcher pina and down to third goes
ortega
it almost looked like it was fouled by
wisdom but he checked his swing and the
ball kicked off the mitt of the catcher
pina tau tishner is a home-plate umpire
i think council's saying you got to ask
for help on that clearly hits the bat
you can almost hear it there's no
question to hit the bat to me
from 2-0 to 2-2 wisdom takes strike
three call wisdom caught looking cubs
don't score leave a man 90 feet away no
score second hunting the batter frank
schwendell
two and two the count on schwendell
and a fastball right by him boy
freddie's got to crank it up today it's
a warm day
two down bases empty for andrew roman
strike three called romine
is gone and so are the cubs we go to the
third nothing nothing game game one of a
day night double
scoreless game third inning and the
better now is colton wong
that one drilled out towards right
center ortega glides across makes the
catch
and justin steele
looking sharp so far
al contra leads off the third swings and
smacks one fare inside third bouncing
off the sidewall it carries right to
garcia and alcantara will have to hold
with a single
back to the top of the order and raphael
ortega
line to the base hit out into right
center
he's two for two alcantara not stopping
ortega as that ball was overrun sprints
to second it'll be a single and an error
and they're two aboard
with one out
raphael ortega's like what do you mean
this guy's hard to hit give me this
nonsense about a 136 batting average
against i think a thousand against a
blind drive single first time up line
drive single this time second and third
one down
and he hit him
contreras
getting plunked right there the 13th hit
by pitch
peralta under duress reaching back time
for a little something extra loses
command
off that top hand he's been hit 13 times
four of the times
against the brewers
clean up hitter patrick wisdom let's see
if he can deliver with the bags loaded
they all pitch
and he walks in a run he was patient
enough to take the walk and the cubs
strike first one to nothing and you
never know in a seven inning game game
might be on the line right here with
this one two and two the count
and dygman in the air
left field taylor runs it down
tyrone taylor got a great break on it
makes the play to end the end owen won
the count to adonis
sadamas goes to right field
and
that is going to bounce oh it's into the
basket that's a home run for adamus
circle them all
william thomas with a home run to tie it
his 21st right on cue
now he just keeps on delivering singing
this guy's special escobar upright
stance from the right side
the pitch
this is grounded fair ball down the
first base line it'll roll into right
off the sidewall picked up by dykman
throw to second the slide
in time
so a double
for escobar
back-to-back hits here in the fourth
inning home run and a double here is ava
garcia
garcia
high drive deep left center
she's gone
two-run blast for ravi garcia
and just like that the brewers take the
lead
that was a no doubter by garcia
number 20 of the year for amazil and now
he had here's the three two at a hamp
swing and a miss strike three and the
cubs
are retired in order hap strikes out for
the third time today we go to the sixth
inning brewers three cubs one sixth
inning two down nobody on for lorenzo
kane
on the other side in june and july that
ball's hit well
and that's got a chance and it's up and
out of here
lorenzo kane
a little two-strike magic as he goes
deep
two out home run for lorenzo kane makes
it four to one brewers
bottom of the sixth inning patrick
wisdom first up the third time through
the order little dribbler third base
side peralta bare hand and he threw it
away and into the camera well
tough play to make at this stage of the
ball game and legs get a little wobbly
pitching in the heat frank schwendel the
batter
on the ground backhanded off the glove
of aureus and then kicks out of play
wisdom will take second a run in and now
it's 4-2
going for this ball down the line slides
kind of and over plays the ball
they are loaded now the tying run is at
second the potential winning run is at
first and patrick wisdom is coming up
one-two pitch and a swing at a miss he
struck him out
got him with a change-up
devin williams with a k
wisdom is gone two outs in the inning of
the first strikeout for williams
greg dykman coming up to bat
one ball two strikes we do it again here
it comes
and he got him struck him out with a
high fastball
98 mile an hour gas williams notches his
second big league save
and the brewers win the first of a
doubleheader today